welcome to this video yes this looks a
bit different right but I have some
things to say about this channel in
general um yeah to be honest I'm doing
this channel for close to three years
now and I still have none the stood them
haven't understood to have not
understood some some basic things in
YouTube I'm honest with you one of those
is playlists I am never use them for for
stuff that I actually watch and also
never really cared much about them in
regards to their own videos but I got
them I got some messages from time to
time telling me you should organize your
playlist and I'm not really sure if I'm
doing it hit the right way but I I put
in some work on that and I just wanted
to show you briefly what now is
available here on the channel I have set
up playlist some 33 playlists and total
and of course this will be more from
time with with with more videos to add
there might be new playlist or not might
be there for sure will be new ones I
just wanted to show you briefly how I
organize things because this might help
you to find some videos and maybe use
them to your to your benefit um so what
have I done I have from set up those 33
playlists with some some some certain
system and what I did is I sought it
first the tournament's that are covered
with the years and month when they took
place so if you look at my playlists and
actually sort them alphabetically like I
did here I have it in German here but I
guess you you can guess what is meant by
all this so I have it sorted so it
starts with the world champ it should
match 2012
in May and no Beall in July rapid to our
championships Dorfman this was a
german-language the Chess Olympiad and
so on we have all the tournaments that I
covered with daily gamed videos recaps
or even more we can see that I did yeah
14 or here 15 videos for tata steel all
the rounds plus some additional stuff
nine rounds and 13 for for the Norwich
as I did daily reports on the candidates
and so on so you find all the major
tournaments that I covered once in a
while I only did one or two videos on a
tournament then I didn't set up a
playlist we'll come to that later this
goes all the way to the dashing off
memorial in in april i did a very huge
coverage of the candidates 2014 66
videos all games it's a huge effort if
you watch all that i mean i'm quite
curious how many hours is that 28 hours
for the real aficionado ok so in the
last tournament that I covered in detail
was the gas room of Memorial in April um
next one of course will be Norway chess
starting on I think on tuesday june june
third will be the first round jun 2nd
will be a starting blitz tournament okay
so all those that start with the year
our tournament reports then the next one
here is here just explained on chess
explain my own over the board games this
is 16 videos i collected all what i did
i can go in there there is the my your
car tournament i recently uploaded all
the rounds i did some videos on earlier
games of mine here
Master Hoffman Grand Master see breasts
I had a blitz game against German
champion daniel friedman where could
have one nicely but didn't manage and
some other stuff that are played in over
the board games it's it's tournament
chess there's only this exception from
this the splits game excerpt so I'm
above my my own over the board efforts
okay then we come to the next sort of
category in which i call enjoy chess
this is this these are playlist which
mostly cover classic games they're also
meant to to be a be teaching material
you of course will learn things if you
watch the the comments and listen to the
comments about the main focus of those
yes also to just enjoy great chess yeah
F this big playlist here with 20 games
by carlson and Anand which I did them
before the World Championship match just
fantastic chest by those two great
players there is some the modern
classics serious which I had started
with 55 great games this should be
continued at some times I have some
ideas about it and that it will
definitely continue in in some form then
we have an joy chess playlist which
covers single games where I just had you
have thought this is a nice game I
should show it it has no big grand
scheme behind it it was just a single
videos that I found and there are really
some nice ones in there I did for it for
for for example for our broadcast of
chronic Aronian in 2012 long stuff some
nice games here this was a very nice one
chest explained what is the phone I had
a game against my my iphone and and when
I searched for similar combinations I
found
fantastic game that I cover TM and yeah
some some games that I just liked and it
also has some one or two tournament
recaps where I just covered one or two
games from a tournament which does not
really warrant its own playlist so the
enjoy chest is for if you just want to
watch great chest go there and there's
still some things too yeah to to take
Notre for your own games then we have
got the learn chess category and this
already has a couple of series learn
chess has got book reviews we've got
five book ribs in there and games only
two videos this will be much more in the
future I have some some plans for that
there will be a much more here in the
endgame sanctions in the future I have
done some opening serious I have the
chess openings on calvert series why I
presented three openings or opening
lines and gave an overview this is also
something to to expand in the future I
had a 44 game series to play against the
London system with black and I had the
two repertoire series the black
repertoire with a 45 which still needs
to be completed and the deform
repertoire for white 15 videos one of
the older repertoires but very very nice
stuff ok this is the launch s category
as mentioned there will be far more
videos in this in this areas in the
future the last category of plainness is
the live chess category which you
probably missed already because these
are the yeah the most the biggest video
count got five minute blitz games all
five minute blitz games I in there more
than 1500 videos note that there is a
couple of more listed then you actually
see because I have produced some
beforehand that are scheduled to be
released
in the next couple of days I have 170
videos here in German language blitz
chess and German language if you are if
you speak and understand German it's
funny funny to watch it's the first
these are the first videos that are
actually recorded from 2011 July mostly
and this is back in the day when I still
smoked like a chimney quite quite quite
funny or disgusting to watch whatever
you want I'll listen to constantly smoky
during the videos um ok next one is live
chess 15-minute rapid games the
15-minute games already are close to 180
videos in there the longer time control
games were have more time to explain I
DSN 10 points next one is live chess
blitz kibitzing very popular where I
just watch other people play mostly a
strong players grandmasters I've got
someone a camera in there but also yeah
Timmy tee and raking yessir Sarah want
some strong GM's playing when when I was
just watching live and cute Singh um
then the popular little serious that
also will see more in the future is my
matches against the computer here on
chess com where I played some some
matches not scoring very much but people
liked obviously to to see me being
slaughtered by this machine so this
category I got got on plane list then I
got another playlist for my own life
chess I called him more online blitz
yeah what is this I played a ton of ton
of stuff where which does not fit into
the other categories are played bullet
matches was asking crusher where we both
did commentary i played bullet against
him I played I played three minutes on
icc those kind of
45 minutes or three minutes chess i
played chess 961 stride that do a comity
for 15 minute games oh no this is
whatever I did I just those those single
games where I Oh blitz sessions whatever
everything else is in there where I
played live blitz um and the last one
here is a live chess chess cube I played
the ton of chess Qbert tournaments I now
put them all in one playlist I really
search for them because in my channel I
had I had two more than 30 31 I had
actually and they were all labeled
differently the name convention was a
mess and now I sorted them all and got
them into some some decent naming scheme
so you can actually tell them apart so
all this is now easily easily a findable
yeah this is just an overview what's
what's on this channel and what is now
sorted by playlists I hope it is helpful
to some people to to find things also if
you have an idea what kind of playlist
would make sense an additional one or
some other yes system tour for this that
might be helpful please suggest and put
it in the comments to the video I'm
really not a YouTube expert I mean I'm
I'm very am very busy and willing to put
in time to produce content as you know
but i'm not a big expert on the inner
workings of youtube so if you have some
improvement to suggest them i'm very
glad to hear it okay thanks for watching
this I hope you um yeah can can use some
of those new features thanks for
watching